So to do this, we'll define a Dish class, that both the main dish and Appetizer
classes inherit from. And Dish will have both init and str methods for
initializing and representing the Dish as a string. In both main Dish and
Appetizer, we're going to, to need to override those methods to provide the
additional behavior that we need for the extra attributes of sides and serves.
So that's one approach. Let me show you what that looks like in code. Here's
what that looks like in code. We're defining in the Dish class, its base class
is object, it's an init method, initializes all these attributes and we've got
the two with default values. And its str class turns it into the string using
format like this. This is a little complicated, but you've seen this code
before, so I won't describe it again here. Then the MainDish class is a subclass
of Dish, so its base class is Dish. It uses super here. It uses super to get the
Dish in it method and adds sides to it. And in the str method, it uses the super
classes str method, and it adds the extra information about the sides. The
appetizer cost is similar, it also inherits from Dish. In this case, we're
adding Serves and we're adding the information about Serves. We avoided a lot of
duplication by using the super str method and the super init method to inherit
those from the Dish class. If you don't like all the supers, there's another way
we might do this. We still have the same class hierachy and we still have the
same init methods. But, instead of overriding str in main Dish and ppetizer,
we're going to have an extras method. And what extras will do is print all the
extra information about that particular type of Dish. So here's what that code
looks like. This is all the same. We've changed the str method for a Dish by
adding extras to it, and extras is the result of calling the extras method on
self. Now, we can define MainDish like this. Note that we don't need a str
method in MainDish. We inherit exactly the str method as defined in Dish and we
add extras that prints out the number of sides. Similarly, we can define
Appetizer. We don't need a str method and define extras to return a string
giving information about how many people it serves. Which of these two is
better? Matter of opinion, I think this one is not yet better. The way to make
this one better would be to use has attribute to make it so it works for other
kinds of dishes which we haven't defined yet that don't even have an extras.